a single very strange woman
may be jeopardizing what could be a
coming Trump indictment out of the
Georgia grand jury that ended its work a
few weeks ago let me set this up and
this is this is weird and cringy and
just bizarre
um one of the members of the grand jury
in Georgia that recently finished its
work issued its report and apparently
some indictments are coming although we
don't yet know whether Trump himself is
going to be indicted has been on a very
strange media tour that I can't imagine
is useful to anybody other than maybe
herself she is uh named Emily Coors and
she was the foreperson of this grand
jury in Georgia
she has been going around giving
cringy interviews speaking in a bizarre
way and I don't know if you know uh I
just don't know what the I don't know
what why everything about this woman is
so strange but she is according to Legal
experts potentially
jeopardizing the indictment of Donald
Trump we're going to play a first clip
here from MSNBC her demeanor is bizarre
it's cringy it's strange but most
importantly this could really be I mean
the the giddiness and even just I listen
under the best of circumstances this
probably isn't a good idea before
indictments are announced but in
particular her demeanor and her
giddiness and everything about it is
it's not helping anybody other than
maybe Trump did you personally want to
hear from the formula I wanted to hear
from the former president but honestly I
kind of wanted to subpoena the former
president because I got to swear
everybody in and so I thought it'd be
really cool to get 60 seconds with
President Trump of me looking at him and
being like do you solemnly swear I'm
beginning to swear him in I just I kind
of just thought that would be
oh my God this is this is very much not
good guys this is very very much not
good awesome moment I can see it would
have been awesome not indicated by the
facts not necessary uh out of a sense of
Duty and Justice it would have been
really cool and awesome to subpoena
Trump oh trying to get the former
president to come talk to us would have
been
a year in negotiation by itself so it
sounds like that was ultimately a battle
that you all decided not to wait exactly
that's that's kind of how it ended up
was that
I'd be fascinated by what he said but
do you think he would have come in and
said anything groundbreaking or just the
same kind of thing we've heard
so at some point you don't need to hear
50 people say the same thing you know
what I mean at some point you kind of
start to get the gist
um God I just then she went on CNN and
it was an equally bizarre interview
you know it's interesting that just
raises more questions I know I know I'm
sorry no no do please do not apologize
I'm very appreciative of your time when
you say there's no plot twists and you
know people won't be shocked people are
gonna people are gonna hear that and
they're gonna think that means that
Donald Trump is definitely on that list
um
I know it's delicate but can you can you
speak to that I can't
well I understand I might be able to
according to instructions but I don't
want to I don't want to speak out on
something that the judge like I said
consciously chose not to release at this
point I don't know if I would interfere
with the DA's investigations I don't
know if I would interfere with
procedures in some way I just I very
much do not want to cross that line
but in your view people will not be
surprised when they see the list of
names to come out who you recommended to
face indictment especially if they've
been following the investigation
I I can't see it being a shocker
you know Donald Trump put up this is
just such a terrible idea statement last
week about the partial report that the
judge did release the pages that he did
and the way that he described it is he
said that yet your report means total
exoneration for him is how he put it in
his statement what's your reaction to
that Emily
um
I did see that today uh which was
fascinating I'm not
positive he read the right document
but um I will say that if what he was
talking about was our statement where we
indicated that there was no evidence of
widespread fraud or widespread vote
fraud in the Georgia 2020 election
that might have been what he meant other
than that I'm not positive what he meant
by that so anyway as fascinating as this
is uh this is potentially a really
really really bad thing and here on CNN
our former federal and state prosecutor
Eli honig explaining it all to Anderson
Cooper
perspective now from CNN senior legal
analyst Ali honig former assistant U.S
attorney he's also the author of the new
book Untouchable how powerful people get
away with it also with us our chief
political correspondent and co-anchor of
CNN's State of the Union Dana Bash
um first of all why this person is
talking on TV I do not understand she's
clearly enjoying herself yeah um but I
mean is this responsible she was the
four person of this grand jury this is a
horrible idea and I guarantee you that
prosecutors are wincing watching her go
on this I was wincing just watching her
eagerness to like you know hint at stuff
it's painful in that respect this is a
very serious Prospect here we're talking
about indicting any person you're
talking about potentially taking away
that person's Liberty we're talking
about potentially a former president for
the first time in this nation's history
she does not seem to be taking that very
seriously there's no reason for her to
be out talking about there's none right
it's a prosecutor's nightmare mark my
words Donald Trump's team is going to
make a motion if there's an indictment
to dismiss that indictment based on
grand jury impropriety she's not
supposed to be talking about anything
really but she's really not supposed to
be talking about the deliberations she's
talking about what specific Witnesses
they saw what the grand jury thought of
so you get the picture now a couple
people a couple of you emailed me and
said David is it possible that she is
pretending and playing a character in
order to derail the entire thing I don't
know everything about this is so weird
that the truth could be anything Trump
already launching an attack on her on
his platform truth social posting quote
this Georgia case is ridiculous a
strictly political continuation of the
greatest Witch Hunt of all time now you
have an extremely energetic young woman
the get this four person of the racist
DA's special grand jury going around and
doing a media tour revealing incredibly
the grand jury's inner workings and
thoughts this is not just this this is
an illegal Kangaroo Court Atlanta is the
leading the nation in murder and other
violent crimes all I did is make two
perfect phone calls now not everybody's
reactions to this this are saying
Charlie Kirk for example said that the
woman is a witch yeah it's really funny
someone might go to jail and have to
spend hundreds of thousands of dollars
to defend themselves
but that warrants a giggle now maybe
that was just a nervous giggle because
you're in front of millions of people
making a complete fool out of yourself
and now we learn about her love of
alchemy no joke she posts on her social
media page about herbs about casting a
circle demonic circles how to cast
spells not a joke this is all on her
social media page yeah now this is why
you don't go out and do a media tour so
I hope that this doesn't derail whatever
was coming I hope it's not used in the
future as Ellie honig suggests for a
dismissal but this is a very very bad
idea and now all we can do is wait
I like wine but I know very little about
it and I am completely clueless when I
go to a wine shop I just don't know what
I'm looking for I don't know what I'm
looking at I couldn't tell you anything
about varietals or if there's hints of
Persimmon or any of it and so if you're
like me wishing you had a seasoned
expert by your side when you're choosing
wine crunchy red fruit is the answer
crunchy red fruit delivers Choice
handcrafted small production wines right
to your door every bottle is hand-picked
by owner and master sommelier Jackson
rohrba in Seattle and comes with food
pairing suggestions we've been chatting
with Jackson his curating puts an
emphasis on organic low intervention
wines wines without artificial yeasts or
chemicals crunchy red fruit sources from
small scale sustainable Vineyards and
only wines that are true to their
location and grape crunchy red fruits
bi-monthly wine club is called the
circle every two months you'll get three
or six bottles to enjoy with videos to
help you appreciate what you're drinking
go to crunchyredfruit.com use the code
Pacman for twenty dollars off a single
purchase or if you join their bi-monthly
wine club send a message to circle
crunchyredfruit.com after you sign up
and they'll take twenty dollars off your
first shipment the link is down below